The gates of uh paradise are open and
the gates of hell are closed. Does this
mean that we will be going to paradise
if we die in this blessed month?
>> Then anyone who dies but naturally go to
Jenna because the gates of hell closed
and Jenna open. Does it mean that even
if a non-Muslim dies in this month even
he'll have to go to Jenna? The reply to
this question is when Allah says that in
this month of Ramadan the gates of
heaven are open it means the gates of
heaven are inviting you to enter Jenna.
That means that even if you do a small
deed, Allah subhanana wa ta'ala will
multiply your reward. And as a prophet
said that every deed will get a reward
10 times and in this month it's very
easy to enter Jenna. When a prophet said
the gates of hell will be closed
indicating that to enter hell is
difficult in this month. Why? because
the tawa level rises
and the chances of you to commit sin is
less and furthermore if you fast the
full month in the month of Ramadan
seeking Allah's reward all your past
sins will be forgiven so the moment a
person fast in this complete month of
Ramadan seeking Allah's reward all his
past sins are completely forgiven so if
the past sins are forgiven the chances
of him going to hell is nil
but what we have to realize the criteria
For the gates of heaven to be open and
the gates of hell to be closed is that
you have to